oh [ __ ] that was fast
this update seems like are we live
already
we are still live i think i mean this
wouldn't be a live stream without us
verifying tell us can you hear us
can you see us can you see us if you can
hear us let us know and then we can just
kick off this stream
right away you know how it goes boogie
where's the chat where is the chat
obi-wan kenobi says yes
hello obi-wan kenobi what's up how are
you doing today yep there we go we're
starting it hello there
thwipster what's up my friend in the
house imam plays
the chankster dark master reaction
i think i know what your channel is
isaac will return
meme god bradley bledsoe what's up my
friend
tm deontay w tongue punch fart box
yes mercy dominic kalani
i'm shattering everyone's name as quick
as i can right now justin martinez
dakota
hello hello isaac we'll return mr knight
thank you for returning
we've returned guys it's been a while
since we've done a live stream this is
kind of a last-minute decision
obviously otherwise i might have
mentioned it yesterday but that's the
way we do all our live streams they're
all last minute and we just like to hang
out for a little bit jen smith of course
i know who you are
jen it's good to see you um hey koi
jonjo what's up right there buddy boy
you're supposed to call me back
[ __ ] oh you're supposed to call
me back coy
what get how was wonder woman by the way
how was wonder woman 84 last night was
it did it treat you good
i got it i gotta text you blue cree
thank you so much for being here
so i thought today for today's stream
that we would do a topic
i'm most excited to talk about merry
christmas to everyone who's here right
now
um so as as a as a deadpool is a great
answer they already kind of do a holiday
special
i believe they in a sense yeah i think
they did thank you brittany lang
thank you for the super chat brittany we
do have super chats open and stream labs
i totally get there's i totally get it's
holiday time
you've probably already contributed a
lot to get presents for your family and
all that
so seriously even though i'm throwing it
out there but no means a pressure to do
so we just want to interact with
everyone okay yeah
so today's stream will be holiday
specials
films that deserve a holiday special now
i'm seeing a lot of comic book movies
here spider-man coy in the chat saying
deadpool
guys listen listen listener right
[ __ ] this is there's only one
movie
one franchise that i really see
truthfully deserves it and if you follow
me on twitter
you'll know i've gone back and forth
with a lot of individuals about this
it's the fast and the furious franchise
fast and the furious
lends itself to a holiday special and
you cannot disagree with me
you can't argue with me on that think
about it it's already about
family and you can already see the plot
forming
in your head when you just say
fast and furious holiday special santa's
in trouble
they need to go out there they need to
go the family needs to work together
to deliver presents all around the world
on christmas day
for other families the fast and the
festive the the fast and the festive
there's your tagline families the family
gonna be helping out
other families no other holiday special
there's no other there's no other
special that could actually
nothing trumps that i got a few in my
mind
i got a few john do you have a special
one you'd like to contribute and then we
want to go to the chat to see what else
is going on in here um
i mean yeah if you if you've been on
patreon you know what my wishes
are but personally i think that
especially with the popularity of films
such as the santa claus and home alone
you could have a perfect inroad in
another franchise that has such a long
continuity and such a history of
moral plays which is why i think we need
a saw christmas
special because think about it what
would be a more justifiable reason
for jigsaw to bust out his tools
teaching people to appreciate
life maybe santa's got a list of naughty
kids
growing every year people are getting
complacent no one cares about being good
anymore they need a little bit bigger
incentive than just a playstation or
something
that's where jigsaw comes in that is
what i want
that is uh john tends to go for the
horror
every single time yeah every single time
jen smith in the chat is saying
i will die on the boys christmas special
oh
now that would be fun actually i could
see a version of that working
where they the and the boys in order to
regain
you know positive reception back with
the audiences
they decide that they're gonna deliver
presents and homelanders
through your chimney bursting through
that door and then what are they going
to leave out for
homelander cookies and
breast milk you guys know it if you
watch the voice yep
you know cookies and breast milk family
is leaving out
coronas for santa and then yeah cookies
and breast milk for homeland
country boys keep saying spider-man 3
should be a holiday special
there should be an avengers holiday
special there should be
like avengers age like you know there's
a consortium enough now that like there
could be a holiday party and something
goes awry and then they have to team up
together but also
with the spirit of christmas in mind
it'd be perfect i think what you
also could do is a pirates of the
caribbean holiday special
that'd be a good one where um you know
captain jack
who's not gonna be in the next pirates
of the caribbean apparently
captain jack sparrow and um
and his dad played by keith richards
have to venture to the north pole for
some reason and then you get like a
horror
kind of north pole you know how powerful
the caribbean does it
they have to go work with santa claus in
some way i feel like that would be a
really solid one
i want ocean's 25 where danny ocean
wants to
break into santa's workshop and he needs
25
celebrity characters to do so that's not
bad because i mean those movies are
already like hanging out so if you just
put christmas around it i don't know it
could be fun
why not they've already broken the
fourth wall so many times in those films
actually a lego a lego holiday special
like once from the lego movies would be
a perfect one
just like this the straight up lego
movie one yeah the lego franchise yeah i
would love to get a lego if you did the
uh
something with emmett is in there yeah
yeah if you do something with emmett
emmett and wild style having a christmas
and they have to build christmas
you watch them like build the christmas
trees and then it just isn't good
oh my god that would be so much fun
because imaginative christmas power
oh my god a game of thrones mr knight in
the chat game of thrones holiday special
you can have it be with the lannisters
and then they all just start [ __ ]
each other
yes yes and drinking and lots of
drinking yeah it'll just take place in a
whorehouse
come on you know that'd be great i would
like that yeah i think there should also
be a transformers holiday special where
you know
they're just back on earth wreaking
havoc but it's christmas actually
dark master reaction in the thank you to
everyone who's contributed to the super
chats you know our style
yeah we'll we'll get to us we'll
eventually get there
we will get all our time finishing up
yeah we'll get there you know us
um we got this uh uh oh oh [ __ ] i
where'd it go
where'd it go damn there's so many good
topics mission impossible is a good one
uh mr possible is good keep going keep
going up john
wick
it's okay i want an expendables holiday
special where like
they all don't know what to do with
themselves because it's christmas no
one's attacking anything and none of
them have like immediate families and so
like they all
kind of at first try to spend christmas
together but then they're all getting on
each other's nerves and then eventually
after they all fight each other
they come back around to what really
brings them all together and watch die
hard on christmas day
oh my god if they could do a human this
nicholas in the chat of saying
human centipede holiday speech i support
you
if by the end of that movie the family
becomes the a human centipede yeah
that is more of a connective intimate
bond than ever
absolutely i really think i think
i think you're on something nicholas i'm
with you i will
support your kickstarter call tom six
i'm sure he's got time
uh joker holiday special so far we
haven't landed on many that actually
sound
like real holiday specialists without i
don't know
other than the fast and the furious
that's the only one
that actually sounds like it could be
what well cause i guess yeah because
like a holiday
we want a holiday adventure or we would
want one of those holiday specials where
it's kind of a variety show and it's
like oh we're not gonna do the regular
like you know life endangering [ __ ] that
we do like it's more about like you know
bits and fun
like what kind of special are we we
really wanted i don't know i mean
it can't just always be saving santa or
like working his already delivered
presents and i feel like you know a
little bit more about christmas than i
do
i am the lioness in this christmas
special yes during this
podcast i'm gonna stop and explain it to
y'all i mean harry potter is already
christmas movie like people in the chat
are going back and forth about if harry
potter
should get a christmas special but i
feel like every movie
there's a christmas there's a christmas
element to all them they they all
have a quality that makes me want to
watch the most
around the winter holidays and hogwarts
the and you know in the books and the
films like just the world at christmas
time and in the snow is so
kind of warm and beautiful that yeah
like they are sort of an unofficial
christmas franchise anyway that being
said
like a harry potter christmas special
that knows
that it's just about that would be
pretty fun you know if if they're do
they already have the star wars star
wars holiday specials and i've seen the
name mandalorian come up a lot in this
chat so far yes
if they already have that and then if
they're doing guardians holiday special
for disney plus if they did a
mandalorian holiday special and it just
seemed like a one-off
but then without spoiling anything in
case no one has happened to see it
if then actually we thought like oh this
holiday special is just something cute
but then it becomes something integral
to the rest of the story
i'm talking about a couple of characters
reuniting with one another
that would be fun then you find out oh
my god this holiday
because i feel like holiday specials
were just these one-offs right
yeah they don't seem like they're
actually integral to the plot
so so make it like super irrelevant with
like
one major reveal season three
yeah yeah the way how the doctor who
holiday specials
yeah are important to the rest of of the
season that it's going to be entering
you do that with mandalorian reunite a
couple of characters you know what i'm
talking about you know who i'm talking
about oh yeah
boom boo yeah i like jen smith drag me
to hell north pole layover
yeah that's nice drag me to santa's
workshop i feel like that you could come
back to the world of krampus easily and
make like a holiday special if you
wanted to
that's good energy you got there thanks
thank you ah
i'm gonna be up here now for the whole
time i feel like uh yeah you could do a
good job if you uh
if you if you do it that way that would
be a great holiday special
that was awesome i am so excited about
what you're talking about
hey the punisher holiday special
the punisher thanks for joining our live
stream and the punisher holiday special
is just him
trying i just want him not to kill
anybody
all day he's trying to avoid killing
anyone and he can't do it
and he just wants to be nice for one day
out of the year i do think stranger
things
is overdue for a holiday special that's
the kind of show where you could break
out of the continuity just have
something holiday related with all the
characters i mean
the first season already had all the
things with connecting a will
through the christmas lights yeah see
i'm feeling ourselves settling in now
i'm taking you guys through the
psychological process of how these live
streams go that's what i'm going to do
with my christmas gift back to you guys
is tell you the emotional insight into
what happens during our live streams
big bursts of energy bring it down then
you start settling in calmly
yes and i think stranger things would
actually be a really solid one and they
already had kind of a christmas
aesthetic in the first one
you know they had she had to connect uh
talk to will in the upside down and she
used christmas lights to communicate
with him
and i think if you just place a season
of stranger things
during christmas instantly it might not
be a holiday special
but it's a christmas season i don't see
why they can't do that
there's no reason i mean the the rules
are breaking down man you never know i
i feel like it's i'm surprised there
aren't as many
like big branded holiday specials now
maybe it's because the star wars one has
this reputation for being so
silly but yeah like i feel like that's a
cash grab opportunity that a lot of
people wouldn't want to pass up
especially with all these ensembles who
span across multiple franchise
installments it almost seems like
a built-in money printing machine for
any one of these ip holders
um oh oh a kingsman holiday special
wouldn't be bad
no that would be fun i mean you know
what
that could be cool actually because it
could be like
you could actually build a christmas
movie around that word stop we were
talking about john
garth just gave a great one in the chat
where is it
all right let's see what it was where
are you guys before you yes spit ball
too much longer
i have to interrupt you where did it go
damn it
okay garth in the chat said show girls
holiday special
and then they're dancing on north poles
the entire time yeah
yeah oh my god dude you did it you came
up with a great one
a candy cane stripper pole would be so
wonderful oh michael cody castillo back
to the future
let's say doc brown and marty they go
back to when jesus was born
you interrupted me but i interrupted you
just a few moments ago
so i'll let you have that one john
you're okay there
what were you going to say that was my
idea
they go they go to when jesus was born
and uh they accidentally when they they
accidentally run over jesus and they
have to come
and rip through the man they [ __ ] up
christmas
we've ruined christmas we've literally
ruined
everything this holiday this is heavy
duck we've ruined
we've ruined christianity too he's like
marty we have to be more concerned about
jesus
yeah all these years of of of of
capitalist tradition of buying and
trading gifts are gonna go down the
tubes no
marty the child you never know save your
humanity marty you never know what gems
are gonna come
out of these live streams and on the end
to that tune anybody who said rick and
morty i also agree i feel like they
would do one at some point because like
you know i mean
they would exist to partially lampoon
holiday specials as well as make
a perfect example of one so i want a
rick and morty one at some point
um look guys there uh some a couple
people have asked about this in the chat
and i do get attack on titan holiday
special boy open oh
i've asked about this in the chat um and
we're gonna put up
my hero academia i tested out another
upload from our editor bradley blitz
who is in the chat right now bradley um
that
uh it just keeps getting blocked so i'm
gonna put up one
uh tomorrow or in a couple days from now
where you can just have access to the
vimeo links for the reaction and then
you can just come back and watch the
the review just to make life easier
instead of dealing with blocks we want
to get it out there we just want to get
it out there that's all that matters
to see it actually you know a genre okay
after this one will you
get to the super chat so behind oh
so actually a john wick um holiday
special
i've always wanted to see like a revenge
driven action movie but with a christmas
aesthetic
to it like a batman no
no you can't you can't you can only do
fat man once guys you can't ruin that
no like something that's like that has
that you know the way how the first john
wick has these like vibrant
colors yeah of like the uh or like the
new york city night lights and
stuff in the clubs but you do that with
a christmas background and stuff so you
have kind of that
ironic touch to it yeah where it's like
a bloody christmas movie you make john
wick george bailey
and then you have it be some kind of
like yeah really heavy dark night of the
soul that involves a hitman but also
christmas yeah man yeah something like
that like a revenge driven kind of
christmas movie uh that takes place on
christmas and you
you play like christmas music in the
trailers and it's ironic it won't appeal
to a family audience no one's gonna fund
it
damn it that was the original script of
the movie i was gonna announce but then
i just
didn't get picked up adult oriented
holiday specials also elias johnson in
the chat
i was gonna say cobra kai i think would
be a perfect holiday special especially
with how well the
series has taken off and people grew up
with danny larusso
and johnny lawrence be perfect i agree
with you
oh my dude the matrix holiday special
will be perfect and this is seriously
the last one junkie circle of
super chats thank you to everyone who's
contributed i got to make sure we do it
but uh the matrix holiday special what
it could be
is um they they're they're it's just
isolated incident takes place dirt
between matrix one and two
and it's just them on the nebuchadnezzar
hiding away from sentinels
but then they decide to go into the
matrix and deliver
presents to air because they can just
like talk to tank be like
tank we need presents we need
and they just go around delivering neo
just zipping around like santa
naughtiness is bliss and then it starts
delivering everything to everyone you
know
cypher yeah i like it i like science
entire thing
with spider-man 3 announced oh no
which which spider-man 3 though if it's
the sam raimi one we already knew
john i love the jokes and energy today
you always love my shows and energy
let's see what these super chats are all
about
it's all december 23s oh you guys are so
generous thanks thank you
thank you to everyone so much everybody
we're gonna start on
super chat here on youtube and also then
go over to our stream labs
that link is in the box as well uh
brittany lang
brittany ling our canadian lovely woman
we haven't heard from you in so long
it's great to see you here today it's a
lovely christmas surprise hello guys
long time no chat wish you guys a very
merry christmas
oh britney hey merry christmas to you
and your daughter
you're one of the hottest moms i've ever
seen so you just have
yourself a merry merry christmas have
yourself
a merry merry christmas and then uh who
do we got next pop culture podcast
damn it this is this is why we cannot
improvise before we get to we cannot
warm up because we try to honor every
single super chat that we ever get
so we end up blowing our load before
we even have a chance to riff on the
wonderful contribution you guys made
damn it spencer leave your idea leave
your pitch in the
comments and and i'll try and find it
later for the john wick
you want to see for chris but i
appreciate that very much guys
hell's yes living freak
now's a good time to be a freak just go
out there and see what you can catch
freak freely jumanji needs a christmas
special
that'd be a good one actually that will
work itself blend itself really natural
yeah
because jumanji is a board game or a
video game and then
someone could just be gifted jumanji on
that day and then they get thrown into
there and the whole
what they haven't done is the whole
family getting involved in
the jumanji game and that's the one you
do i can already see how it would happen
it's like you it's christmas eve
kid hears the drumming so he busts into
his present early
opens up jumanji and like the family
would like whoever
gave it to him i don't know that my
element might be a mystery or it might
come from the parent or whatever but you
know like the kid gets sucked in first
christmas morning comes
like where's our child it must have
something to do with this
board game that they opened up and then
you know the family gets sucked in that
way they gotta go find the kid but then
when they find the kid they find out
that the kid is like super
well attuned to this game living you
know the way
robin williams or nick jonas did and uh
you got a whole christmas adventure
right there
uh-huh yeah uh-huh uh-huh yeah uh-huh
yeah i feel very supportive totally
uh-huh this was this was my pitch and
and i feel confident enough based on
this reaction to take it to hollywood i
just realized that i've been kind of
mean to you during this live stream and
it's christmas so i got to be nicer and
more supportive even when i don't really
feel or believe it
so just give them sean i i love your
idea
i love the route you took it thank you
um
good job i good job i'm really proud of
you i feel that
i'm really pregnant intrinsically and
guys i do want to throw out there if
there's anyone in the chat
that puts out us an idea for one
or us actually you know what i know you
guys are listening a lot of movies why
don't you also list
some actual ideas to follow up with what
you can do for them
like schindler's list that would be a
beautiful holiday special
those shoes learn about christmas all i
want oh
i'm not going to continue this joke
it's good to see your name once again
bernie says
hi guys i can't wait for the game i am
jesus christ
neither can we face three of us neither
can we
yes if you guys have not seen that
apparently we were so late
finding out about this damn video game
this was
it was a highlight of my week though it
was lovely i was like what the [ __ ]
it was i am jesus christ it's the best
surprise we
gotta we gotta play it together
here's a movie that needs a holiday
christmas special halloween
halloween christmas
yeah what do you call it you just call
it christmas
the other night he came home that year
it was like lori strobe with her family
and all sitting around
all the girls like oh i'm so glad that
michael myers is finally gone and we can
enjoy our christmas
halloween is always a traumatizing time
for us
every year but at least but at least
this time we have christmas or
we fall back on it we can forget all
about that michael myers
boom bust through the window windows
but then by the end michael sits around
the table with them
and then he becomes a part of the family
and then he carves the christmas goose
with his big-ass kitchen knife um oh
okay to honor pop culture podcast we got
to go back a little bit because we we
we didn't really talk much about this
one he said
my pitch for john wick christmas special
is santa hires john to kill some of the
worst
of the worst on his naughty list happy
hall oh that's
good santa's a member of the high table
that's good
you bet your ass he is that's how he's
so omnipotent
he's gonna be murdering so many children
john wakes in a murder so many kids
so many kids on the naughty list
i mean yeah i would love that if it's
only kids on any of the lists
it's not a universe or a santa traffic's
an adult presence john wick finally
becomes
extremely unlikable yeah
yeah but then you know at the very very
end he brings puppies to all the good
children jesus that's
uh that's terrible all right okay
you got the green light as far as i'm
concerned
all right craig stratton thank you craig
i appreciate it
thank you mission christmas impossible
we are the gold standard he's just
yelling at his elves
and then yeah that'd be a perfect stunt
in the stratosphere
what it could be
santa's out of commission and they need
a they need a ride
this is a truly impossible mission that
hunt needs to
run the mission he needs to make sure
christmas happens
they're slacking and they're not
believing that he's just goes through
his tom cruises he's got
benji stationed at the north pole on the
computer
while luther drives the slaves if i see
you pack that package wrong again you're
done [ __ ]
other people are buying gifts based on
what we are doing
i am on the phone with every department
store tonight
guys we love our idea way more than
anyone who's listening right now wait we
can't go too far with this otherwise
they're going to copyright
copyright in this podcast we already
said the words ethan hunt we acknowledge
the existence of mission impossible we
should probably shouldn't reference
santa either coke probably only
thank god but uh mr impossible christmas
is my jam i would love to see that does
the halo jump at the end
out of the sleigh with the sacks gotta
deliver the final presents
oh john these are all good i had a
jarhead christmas special absolutely
you know mall cop as good as those
movies are not
would make yeah it would set itself up
for that
all right peter pacheco what's up my
buddy pdp
happy holidays to you all and the reject
nation
and a firefly holiday special
dude that's what we need right now dude
josh sweden
more just to bring
us a proper christmas to remind us of
the spirit
of equity and respect oh my god and then
and then it should also be
uh and then we should get ray fisher to
star in this firefly holiday special
if you're not present during my jokes
john
i'm always there is a delayed reaction
with your laughter i am here it might
read as a lag on the live stream i don't
want it to it's to appear as
no i'm not actually john is not as
present and then he hears the joke
five seconds after i say it which might
i add was hilarious
you know what let me explain you why
that joke is so funny guys
because ray fisher and josh sweden do
not get along
and who would be a better person
enjoying the firefly cast
out of any actor possible i didn't
expect ray
fisher yeah i should have really been
there just to bat that one around
just saying uh anissa oliva
anisa she is at work right now oh thank
you so much
and she's just stopping by to say hi we
miss you too anissa
talk to you a little bit on the regular
i appreciate it tells you
really appreciate it i hope you're doing
it your boy's asking do y'all want a
hundred dollar donation
is is he gonna ask for a piece of my
toenail
yeah probably he's gonna ask for a part
of your body constantly
up in the chat to make sure to really
riff on a little bit later all right
yeah save it for the free form chevy
reacts over here
merry christmas from malta what's up
malta great to hear from you jeffy
you are what dreams are made of i hope
everything's going okay over there every
time you check in with me
about what's going on with malta it just
sounds like
you're living in a nightmare yeah so i
hope
your christmas this year can just be
ruined
i hope it gets worse on christmas i want
your resilience put to the test
i want your house to explode yeah
i want just random people to come up and
start beating you up this is why people
superchat
yeah if you super chat a 100 donation
this is what she'll give you so you'll
get
a roast ill wishes ill intense
no jeffy i i hope you're i hope you have
a great christmas with your family and
all sincerity and thank you for being
part of our patreon for so long
i seriously do it like every time i hear
from you no matter
how things are going in your neck of the
world you always seem unflappably
positive and i appreciate
your resilience that's true that's true
borderline serial killer
yeah you know pete don one of our
longest patron jigs as well
has said nothing he's living in a void
right now but pete i appreciate the
super chat dude
void christmas special sounds quite
interesting i appreciate that very much
pete i hope you're doing well
merry christmas to you buddy craig
stratton up in here
yeah christmas at the overlook hotel
it would be really cool to actually just
see i mean it would ruin the other
movies
but it would be really cool
it'd be really cool to see what it's
like a day in the life of the ghost of
the overlook hotel because you only see
them when they're like [ __ ] with
actual humans who are there
but you don't get to see what it's like
and and and we established
it snows it's in colorado it's going to
happen what
it's it's a new year's party that the
photo at the end is taken at right
i think so yeah so like there would be
perfect reason to go back
five days earlier a week earlier we
should do a prequel that explores
what led to that photo yeah exactly
what was that week of the last week of
the year like
look guys some of these jokes are gonna
be really good
and some of them are just gonna not
they're gonna be better they're gonna be
not gonna be as good but better yes
one of them right but better yeah
depending on how you look at it
bradley bledsoe what's up buddy thank
you man
bradley oh what a wonderful idea this is
a wonderful idea
i think a bill and ted holiday special
would be so much
fun um you could put on a twist
put on a twist well should i harp on
should i harp on his typo do it do it
always do it make people feel bad for
their grip on the english language
[ __ ] speak right bradley yeah you
sound like an
idiot should i call you i have your
number
okay you can put on a twist on the ghost
of christmas past
present and future with time travel much
love to you both america well merry
christmas to you
and your sexy ass wife one day her and i
we will run away together and then you
can end up with my fiance
oh no never mind i should have oh man if
i didn't keep going
no i could have yes sanded that and that
probably would have been better
trying to give these guys a comedy let's
see i see
no one no one wants the j train um
country boys are saying thousand dollars
i'll do it just say it
i can't give you toenails man but
i will but john will send you a picture
of his toenails if you contribute a
thousand dollars
after but in all seriousness a bill and
ted holiday special would actually be
wonderful yeah
um it lends itself perfect like this
that's a natural one because some of
these holiday special ideas that have
come in here have been like funny ones
obviously but then one like bill and ted
i sincerely would hope that if they were
to do another bill and ted installment
that they would actually go down that
path
yeah harold and kumar could get away
with the christmas special bill and tech
could get away with a christmas special
and you could explore how christmas is
but like exploring the christmas past
present and future with time travel
yeah that's pretty amazing that would
actually be a real
chris that could be a genuine christmas
movie
yeah i love that idea i mean i feel like
yeah there's so many you could also make
it a variety show you could have music
like you could actually have
performances i didn't even think about
the music
perfectly integrated itself you know
there's so many plus you could have
christmas in hell because they got to go
see the grim reaper at some point you
know
all the possibilities i love this
bradley
call up alex winter he said if they
if the right idea comes along and that
sounds like it's
me some of you guys are pitching ones in
the chat right now
that we've already discussed and you got
to understand
we form our live streams for repeat
value always
so you just have to go back come back to
the beginning
listen to us figure out if we went live
and then riff on all of
these hey turek thanks for being here
eddie brock teaches venom
the meaning of christmas it's only right
if they're going to live together on
earth for all this time
keep ripping john oh yes well because
you know it's like how would eddie brock
be able to get venom a christmas present
it's like they're one they're sharing
the same host so it's got to be
impossible to surprise the guy so
like maybe eddie and venom have to
separate for a little bit while they do
their christmas shopping and then you
know oh
who's that it's the michelle williams
character and then she
uh ruins the whole thing and and you
know by pairing with venom again
herself like a mis venom is gonna be
like a mistletoe in this version where
like
eventually eddie and her get like
intertwined inside of him and they have
a holiday kiss it's
so good it's going to be so good and
then we're going
on another we're going to go to another
restaurant keep your venom
going brock is going to like freak out
but at like a christmas restaurant this
time so while people are getting
served their like chinese food christmas
duck eddie brock has to like hop in the
fish tank and be like oh man
oh goodness i'm so proud of you man
whatever's in there
ah venom and then uh oh who's that i'm
done making notes you want you
honored the [ __ ] out thank you super
chat man i
love that idea it was just all passion
say a tire kite die hard holiday special
that's all i have to say i think
die hard is not a real christmas movie
it would be
so cool though if bruce willis came back
and he did give a [ __ ]
if he did care always and he really they
really
amped you know what they have i'm
surprised they haven't done that have
they with any of the die-hards
no they haven't amped up the christmas
quality no they've left it
completely behind that's so easy we
traded it for for
for naked stretches and airplanes and
sam
jackson and and whatever die hard five
was
i whoa they should do another d if they
do another die hard are they talking
about they should
go back exactly like really let it feel
like a holiday movie and play into that
fact
yeah oh maybe they could put it to rest
then be like okay look if everyone wants
people keep saying is die hard a
christmas movie or not you know what
would be good
i think if they made a die-hard
christmas to go on a rent go
and you just interrupted my rent go
what's the rant
well now i lost it i'm just here to
destroy everyone's christmas
i'm here to grinch it okay go ahead go
ahead you ruined christmas for me i'm
just saying go ahead
well anyway i would it would be a
perfect home invasion scenario bring
the threat home to john mcclane out of
you know a building or an airplane or
whatever bring it home he's finally got
the entire family together
and then they are all taken hostage and
then they gotta work together
to thwart the scenario
finally everyone can see what john
mcclane's daily life
is like and they build
they grow as a whole family unit and can
finally live happily ever after
because then we'll know that even if
they get attacked again they
will take care of it what an amazing
idea we are the cnn
of the fox news of youtube live streams
both at the same time if cnn and fox
news were
or just a split screen very very bitter
all the time
but in opposite angles oh i missed a
part in anissa's super chat from earlier
where she set a supernatural holiday
special
dude oh i thought you were just calling
back to the one that we put up on
christmas yes
ruins a rant holiday special that's what
this episode that's
what this episode where's that comment
that's your that's the new pin comment
for the stream
awesome awesome yes i'd like it replace
the pin comment
oh no no john no no it's okay it's okay
we got this
it's okay we got this top one top option
replace ping comments
it's confusing the way they labeled that
yeah oh okay i wanted to make sure we
started
but a supernatural holiday special would
be wonderful yeah
i don't want to talk too much about it
right now for reasons i will not say
but anyhow i agree i would like it that
would be nice
and uh be nice to finally see jesus gene
jeter eight mile holiday special guys
jean jeter is a wonderful youtuber
photographs beautiful woman he does i
got his calendar and himself
obviously dick pics
realize oh he was just really close to
it pulls back
whoa too big anyway
i'm trying to break that down visually
in my head saying it was so close yeah
yeah
that was too small at first it's
obviously small because it's that close
you're like whoa you're like oh it's
like a city down
calm that thing down he calls it the
skyscraper
dude that would be so fun if if eight
mile had a holiday special
yeah yeah wanda fanta don't you want a
buantafanta with santa
dealing with the elf and i felt carving
a glory hole in the north
pole oh dude that's good the north pole
with my glory hole
give him presents start my hoes uh
take a pause from mrs claus as i
pull out my flaws i'm on the naughty
list i call it a [ __ ] list
uh smack elves like jingle bells take my
fist
to [ __ ] rihanna or some [ __ ]
yes i am a rap santa
we [ __ ] that up you got a great line
though one of those was really good
say you we we there were bars between
the both of us and
i would i would say yours was better we
can go uh uh
have these on an eminem pair i would say
you're one a lot better
um random mandy's channel hey merry
christmas to merry christmas everyone
merry christmas happy hanukkah happy
anything else
randy manny's channel zombieland seems
like a great holiday special
maybe shazam would seem cool as well
zoolander would be a ball
ah you know i think out of all well
shazam already took place on christmas
so i don't think we need to do shazam
uh zoolander i feel like zombieland
would be the one that is best
because they are already a family who's
already trying to make
life feel like a family in a time when
it's really hard to feel like a family
so they try to have fun and make the
most of it
and then you even do get what's not
willie nelson what's his name woody
harrelson
you get woody harrison you get willie
nelson you get what do you hear
this is why there's jump cuts in the
videos guys rest is santa
you do get woody harrelson um in
uh the same yeah john finished it you
complete me john
you had me at hello you i got mail
and yeah so yep there we go i think
i mean zombieland [ __ ] i think yeah i
have screwed up your whole super chat
i'm so sorry
it's ruined it doesn't work anymore and
you and hey your profile pic
always looks inside always popping i
know we got some more super chat so i
want to check in with the
just make sure and then we could do
something we also got some stream
labbers
laboratories what's up john no that's
how it is today uh you can you can
refresh it if you like oh damn we got a
few in our
we gotta get we gotta make sure we get
there as soon as possible heckles
yeckles
okay cool but listen i saw someone in
the chat that popped up and i wrote them
down
as you guys were going through some of
the super chats all right
50 shades of grey oh yes
you just get them like the sexy santa
outfits it works perfectly
yeah and then you know you really play
in on like the tension between like oh
man we're being so naughty
they just keep giving each other look
there's no real plot in those movies all
right
what are you talking about there are
people trying to kill them
actually is that movie warner brothers
i'd
because if they if it went on hbo max
they could probably we don't need to
look it up it's okay john
if it were not hgo max there was a
universal bar
if they oh yeah i think you're right
it's so caught up in semantics here if
it went on a streaming
service then then they could go all out
with the sex but yeah they did
absolutely if they did a 50 shades of
gray one and then yeah they're just
getting dressed up sexy santa sexy mr
claus
yeah or santa claus and then they have a
kid
oh they do have a kid spoilers
they have a kid and the kid grows up
very happy and the kid is not confused
at all by his parents lifestyle
and and with a completely vanilla sexual
sensibility actually you could do that
fifty shade sequel like a comedy
yeah about i have my parents and they're
very sexual
and it's really awkward to be around
them during the holidays you could get
away it was great it was
my dad what's his name gray
and anastasia keep [ __ ] at the
christmas table
and i'm just trying to hang out with my
friends and it's really uncomfortable
you could write this oh my god oh oh the
initiative
is that are you uh you're your carlos
oh i was just thinking about you the
other day the first guy that ever
recognized us
i don't think about you way too much man
he just could you confirm that to the
initiative confirm that's you
initially but i was just thinking about
like man remember when that that dude
recognized this a dark light
anyway i think it's a good one being
told about this
uh and then the other one that's the law
of attraction right there where'd it go
why do you have a note that says
indonesia 5 a.m uh let's see here
boba fett holiday special he became
really popular i was in the man
in uh in the holiday special of star
wars so i think actually doing a boba
fett holiday special
would just [ __ ] up everything they have
going right now but i think as
fans we would love it yeah you know see
what christmas is like on good old slave
one
you know you do you know how um in in
the clone wars and rebels the the voice
of captain rex
is supposed to be the same voices as the
as boba fett because
the clones right so if you actually did
a boba fett holiday special with him and
fennec shan
and then you got um the guy who voices
captain rex i don't know who voices him
captain rex and uh
yeah you know what i'm talking about all
the clones then why am i taking so long
to say this one very obvious
cause you're starting that star wars
knowledge yes that's that you go
there and uh and and then uh yeah that
would be that'll be the way to do it
i could i could have really sold that
one a lot better john
you take over the channel ah that's
permanently
who today was decided luke skywalker and
baby yoda there's another one that i
wrote down
that would be a really great one dude
and then you could have
dinjaran like reunite with him at the
end for like a perfect holiday you just
ruined it
yeah it's all right everyone knows sorry
i don't know
about that but maybe that's their first
day together
maybe that's their very first day
together yeah that could be look we need
a bonus we need to form rapport before i
start
training you so here's a present so
here's
i'm just going to give you a lightsaber
i started you off big man
yeah look how cool i of a guardian
mentor i am i just gave you this i'm
talking about [ __ ] now you you
would like and respect me
and then another one that i wrote down
that someone said in the chat
face off they just keep swapping faces
take it away john so uh
come on you cover me i wrote it down and
i thought i had a great one that come to
mind well
nothing came to mind man i mean the
thing is you know being that it's the
holidays
uh uh caster troy and the other guy you
know after all they've been sean archer
they want to get each other faces
of other people to swap oh that's cool
you get four faces
and then all of a sudden you're just
like oh damn we got four people swapping
faces
and then uh at the end of it they gotta
figure out whose face goes back on which
body because they lose
track and then they realize that
christmas isn't about whose face you're
wearing
it's about your bond as a bunch of
psychotic
face swappers you see we see here's what
i'm talking about
wait a minute they have everything
listed here in order of stream lab and
super chat on youtube now i guess that's
yeah why
haven't we just been going off of this
this would have been way more organized
and then we could just go in the order
of which they were received
well we've we're really learning about
this new stream labs update
and uh next time i will absolutely set
it up that way
um look hey someone's saying uh they're
having trouble
with the super chat i'll just put my
bank account number here
in the chat right now along with my
social security card
you can just send it directly to no
forget that let's skip some steps
let's go directly you can send a money
order to our
virtual mailbox send us a check
um that's okay man if you can't it's all
right yeah no worries and then
that is what counts all right okay john
let's see here let's see where are we at
can you can you pull us back up you you
do your thing yeah of course
everything i'm so proud of you and that
was carlos carlos
never forget your name c note he
recognized this at arclight i turned my
head
and he had his jaw just dropped like
this
not even joking if you're watching the
stream you know it and i was i was like
who the hell is this kid who the hell is
gawking at and then he's like
ryan and i'm like oh [ __ ] this guy
recognizes me first guy ever
it was a great day for me and i've been
looking for you ever since carlos
carlos where you been all right john you
got a setup yeah
you got to set up john let me see if i
can blow this up a little bit without a
very good destroying
the setup oh a terminator holiday
special is not a bad idea
at all yeah especially after i mean
all the human sentiments that have been
learned
by these machines like i would love to
see what a
uh christmas holiday like lull is like
for them
you can make a cannon you could do it
where it takes place
during terminator 2 and then it just
happens to stumble upon christmas
at this one point and then they all sit
around and they give each other gifts
perfect i love it they all give each
other guns that's what they do
they all give each other guns that's
what they would need that's the most
practical gift for this world okay
all right where are we at all right flev
doran
yeah this one right here thank you flev
thank you so much how's it going hope
you're well thanks for the
music video recording all right
first off hope you've had a happy
holiday guys
no to the topic only thing that i could
think at the moment is i would love to
see
uh the boys christmas episode [ __ ] that
was like one of the first ones we talked
about
you know we next time homelanders
families living leaving breastfeeding
yeah
don't go to the soup go to the super
chat
stream labs when there's none in there
and just go we're not starting until
it's
not starting to contribute to god
someone gives us an idea we might have
already commented then we'll finally
talk
hence it's the pickle of these we don't
interact unless someone we don't
give us a surprise all right next stream
just just we will not
pose any creative ideas until um
yeah the boys yeah i mean that's where
the families leave out breast milk
yeah two ugly [ __ ] and then you know he
he jerks off on top of the city from
way up high but he's got more ideas and
then oh he jerks off on top of the city
like at the end and then people are like
oh it's
snowing oh my god oh
mic drop resurrect do all cliches have
huey and annie
the boys forbid for dinner okay make
them be cheesy couple that want to make
everyone
sing christmas carols marvin's kids
running around
frenchy trying to explain the traditions
to kimiko butcher sitting in the corner
grumpy with the santa hat on
this sounds like the scene of an episode
that would take place on christmas i
like the last 10 minutes or the
beginning of an episode
where christmas this is the point but
this is a solid idea to do a boys
holiday special
it seems like a setup or a conclusion
yeah it's a bunch
that's all you need for holidays
specials there's a bunch of setups and
then the conclusion
is ah family right but anyway phleb i
appreciate that i hope you're having
them oh wait wait wait what goes on i
got more what goes on
the beat goes on maybe a christmas party
where homelander smiles and greets
everyone
wearing an xmas sweater over his suit
while inside wishing
they'd all be dead maeve be drunk on
punch a train showing off at the karaoke
deep trying to warm himself back into
the seven
yeah by working for like salvation army
it's an extended setup of what he's got
in mind
but you know we still need uh we need to
know like what what goes on as it goes
why christmas but flev you got a great
setup i'd say
yeah great setup keep it i'm just not
sure this is the you know the right
timing right now you know it might not
be the perfect fit for you
keep developing it and uh you know pitch
it pitch it someday
hip man hudson merry christmas love
chatting with you on patreon too
the correct answer i love that the
correct answer
the correct answer the truth is what we
do in the shadows holiday special i mean
i still hate that movie because it's
offensive to my people
we're wolves
[Music]
there's a new zealand guy who's mad at
her we're boobs but still actually what
we do in the shadows holiday special
does make sense and they have a
show on fx so they could just do a
one-off holiday special oh yeah
absolutely and i mean there's already an
episode where they go to
this might be the correct answer yeah
right here there you've done
it man there's already a big party
episode and whatnot and there would be
so many
yeah it would be the perfect fish out of
water scenario all those great
personalities john don't lose that
energy man
don't lose that seriously that's a great
show we're still gonna be live for like
another half hour 40 minutes support
don't use that energy jump
energy all right yeah jack yeah we're
[ __ ] lost here
live it's christmas week let's do this
all right let's cover them covering this
is all that joe
o'keefe thank you joe o'keefe who
submitted my final
christmas essay and my master's today
congratulations
i am nearly a bottle of wine through
ready for some whiskey
i'd love a haircut that's a lot of
alcohol man you should do that in the
reverse order
oh yeah it could be dangerous they say
you shouldn't mix like that i'd love a
harry potter
i hope you're still able to keep super
chatting once you hit super drunk stage
actually it'll help grease those wheels
for you yeah it might you know it might
be okay
yeah just uh stay alive we're at charity
stay here
and uh you know just make sure you have
some buttons ready to push
once the alcohol really kicks in there
just just as long as you're intelligible
enough to let the bank know that all
these transactions are in fact your own
then you know it'll be fine remove your
card right now
don't be irresponsible don't wreck your
christmas don't lose your home in a
drunken stupor
i love a harry potter ho please finish
john please finish it but i was so into
how you were reading that
i'd love a harry potter holiday special
what shenanigans do fred and george
weasley get up to at christmas
all the love from ireland well my friend
from ireland joe o'keefe
i would talk and say to you fred and
george weasley holiday special would
actually be a really
good one yeah actually they'll be the
perfect psych characters to host that
because i think the natural response
when someone says
you know harry potter holiday special
you go
already haul it already takes place
during christmas
but if you have it solely focused on
fred and george weasley
and mrs norris
everyone forgets about mrs norris and
and and filch presumably or just misses
just mrs norris not much of a character
i'll say no but we're really going to
develop mrs newest in this film
yeah she's probably talking about magus
and yeah just george weasley [ __ ]
with people on christmas that would be
great
and with the aging you could do it now
yeah you played fred and george weasley
that wasn't donald gleason wasn't it no
he was born i want to see who's bill or
eric harley he was one of those it was
aragorn
george they're like damn
i think fico mortens to play fred and
george weasley right yeah he got into
his aragorn makeup and then from there
he got into fred
george makeup and that was this whole
process um
let me see here okay ghostbusters
christmas special toy i just previewed
let me hold on oh wait i'm supposed to
be writing down the ones
elias fast and furious was my first one
don't you forget
make a ghostbusters christmas special
where there's ghostbusters
are trying to teach peter venkman a
lesson but instead of
learning he's just trying to suck him up
hokey i love you too
meernum you're so sweet to us okay oh oh
okay oh okay we've entered territory
here that is different
all right oh oh look at that we're
organizing oh dude
see recognize see the dream is already
christmas is really
christmas organization christmas
structure
we don't have to keep we don't have to
keep clicking around we all gotta do
nothing anymore
parasites holiday special brilliant
ideas yes daniel gomez writing that
yes just make the same movie but add an
element where people are sneaking
christmas presents
i gotta download this stream and
re-upload it with photos
absolutely i think that's the way to do
it make it more engaging
we you know we could flash photos up on
screen
it would take a little bit of you would
never you would never listen to the
conversation
we would need a third person in the
booth like every show
has their like you know engineer
producer cam veggie's asking in the chat
what is your advice for growing a new
channel my advice would be
ask tyrone magnus he's got
he actually has videos about becoming a
youtuber yeah
and and water it every day all right we
got a living freak in here
living freak living freaks's
no country for old men holiday special
it's the [ __ ] would that be what is a no
country for all that
yeah that would be that you would think
of it possible no scenario that's the
feeling it would leave you with
what but it would be you know tommy lee
jones uh
you know reflecting once again on some
kind of weird nihilistic crime that took
place
it would be like fargo would it have
anton chagur
a in a christmas outfit yes it would be
standing but instead of the cow
execution thing he would have one of
those salvation army bells
you know it would be you know but no
seriously cam veggie tyrone has some
great videos on becoming a youtuber i
think i think they're really worth
watching
um uh what would be a great no country
for old man holiday special
is you know he needs a job anton chagor
so he becomes a mall santa
it's a land diaries so then sans so then
kids sit on his lap
yeah it's your lucky holiday
i want it i want that bowl cut and a
beard
mirage thank you living freak hap merry
christmas niraj merry christmas to you
buddy it's good to hear from you niraj
whatever you guys write next should be a
christmas special merry christmas
we came up with a christmas special
sketch way too late in the game
and so it'll come out next year and
it'll only take about a day to shoot
yes we just got stuck up on we just
didn't have time
for the day to do it but next christmas
get ready get hyped we haven't been live
in in all
all like i think we have most of the
band we've gone all
month is our first time being live this
month yeah definitely in december
and definitely probably within a month i
need the release i need the release of
being here with you guys
it just feels too good it's a nice
catharsis and it's nice to feel your
presence
but niraj merry christmas to you yes we
will one day have a christmas special
sketch and because it'll just be
exclusively a sketch
no one's gonna watch it yes exactly when
it's just an isolated sketch not that at
the beginning of a review or reaction
or people think they're stepping into a
reaction nobody watches that sketch
we'll just upload the entire thing on
the front of that year's avengers
trailer and have everyone get upset
about it
um f clone in the chat i am not a
college kid and it's always sunny in
philadelphia i was a high school kid
underage drinking
craig starting stratton planet of the
apes holiday special
celebrating caesar's birthday caesar is
the jesus of that universe
was wait a minute was craig i mean not
craig who was cracking planet
was uh was was caesar in
like did they ever it was his birthday
on christmas or are you just like making
a cannon now that caesar's birthday
takes place during
christmas either way all right i'm
getting too caught up in the specifics
of it
but but but you know if the pla
if it is the planet of the apes they
might have some type of actually you
know having a christmas aesthetic with
planet of the apes might look really
nice
yeah i mean it would be showing sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i get it paul's
showing i paused and gave you an
opportunity to speak and i just
didn't let you take that opening and i
cut you off right when you started
please john my gift to you is you
talking well i mean i'm just used to all
the planet of the apes there have been
some that you know like
wolfpota takes place in the snow i guess
but you know we've never seen just in a
beautiful uh you know winter scenario
and uh you know maybe yeah it could be a
thing that brings humans and apes closer
together like oh what's this
human prisoner doing oh damn he's making
himself a little tree and putting stuff
under it what are you doing little guy
oh damn this is like a tradition that
you guys had and it's built on
love and compassion and humanity we
could all tap into that
here in the ape society caesar
you're our jesus i just wanted to say i
think the apes are kind of being
portrayed like you know they're always
in violence and i just want to see them
get along i just want a 90-minute movie
of no conflict
absolutely just just petty squad just
them getting along
having a good time yeah doing family
things doesn't always need to be [ __ ]
dark and heavy i mean they're apes
they just want to live their lives
things go well on the planet of the apes
that's the next
movie a fine day on the planet of the
apes
joy on the planet of the age summer
vacation on the planet of the year
you call it christmas with the planet of
the ape christmas on the play yeah
christmas with the planet of the apes
yeah
perfect green light that and we get
matt reeves to direct it still saya
kite my catchphrase i appreciate your
existence
oh that's a good one see ya thank you so
much
what a beautiful catcher i appreciate my
existence too
i appreciate some of john's existence
i appreciate most people's existence in
this chat
i mainly just care about my existence
you know that is the sort of nexus of
all your experience so
i'm just saying that a lot of you guys
aren't like don't matter to me if if i
go
then what are your lives going to become
i think therefore what are all of you
i think this bit is great it's doing
great it's the best one this is going
exactly for
our imagination
we had a sketch we had to can it and bam
plucked right from that sketch
put it over here yep we were like oh and
a perfect end
wow for the bit so good we worked on oh
my god
i feel transcendent in this moment now
david lynch
i am very happy for everyone who's here
i'm very
grateful for everyone's existence over
here like what i just want
everyone every time we go before we go
live only thing i say to john is
let's just entertain whoever's here
let's just have fun and entertain
whoever's here
that's pretty you know anything i need
to add on in that sentence and every
time i tell him i'm not recording you
yeah but no that is absolutely true i
mean
i'm not recording but no it's true like
we always that's what we always say and
i feel like we never
we never get to do that we never bring
you any joy
you guys are trending right now that
would be [ __ ]
that would be cool that'd be so crazy
just
wake up to twitter just everywhere i was
just joking tm stay
i was joking hey chelsea nice to see you
oh
christina if those are thank you
christina if there's a showgirl special
how about a magic mike special
dick in a box dude and the movie can be
called
magic mike xx mass
magic mic drop magic
oh that was good thank you that was good
aye magic mike drunk that was good that
was a good house
dude the magic mike xx missed
oh my dude call channing whoa let him
know
i i've got an idea for him did you just
get a haircut
something's different about you did you
get some boner pills
what's going on you got new shoes man
that was good john
you trim your beard i really like that
oh
i'm here all night we are till
till late thank you christina for that
we're only 40 minutes behind
according to here it says exactly how
far catching
up and in this free refresh so
so doing doing it well nick clark nick
clark rocking christmas eve thank you
nick clark krampus the sing-along
holiday special
hey hey
get all those krumpus knocked tunes that
we don't sing much
you know that that need exposure here
rosie beatty has entered the chat
darth yodah zero six sixes herrera
listen to the chat
um yeah i mean a krampus sing along
holiday special
i feel like krampus should be more in
the zeitgeist around christmas
you know i know it's a niche thing man i
feel like christmas horror is
underappreciated especially
based on a creature that is like foreign
well you know maybe that'll replace a
christmas story someday as the all-day
christmas day marathon
oh my god tana christmas special it
would be the most
emotionally void christmas movie
jesus is born backwards and forwards
out of time rackadilly i didn't even see
you there
tm look guys trademark guys
look tm we got to make this good because
i'm worried he took my joke seriously
about the whole existence
thing i don't want to [ __ ] i don't want
to ruin my relationship with tm tm
i'm sorry transcendental meditation i'm
like i know i'm sarcastic and then every
once in a while you know like you're
like
so sarcastic is he ever sincere and then
once in a while make a sarcastic joke
that people take seriously then i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's what they took me
literally for that's right we're talking
about tm
hi guys merry christmas eve
eve um well in some parts of the world
like for darth yoda zero six six it's
probably christmas eve
for her merry christmas if i'm doing my
time correct on what time it is in the
uk
if if it's not it's very close
hi guys merry christmas eve eve i'd love
to oh my gosh i said not a problem we
don't even need to read a super chat now
okay we're moving on
all right skip any of the tms i'd love
to see a holiday special
with the suicide squad with a series of
bloody
and holiday relate hey could you guys
hit the like button if you're still here
i'd love to see a holiday special with
the suicide squad the series of bloody
and holiday related missions oh
man a suicide squad holiday special some
kind of
holiday special actually out of any of
the dc
movies to take place during christmas
you know what i want to take the time
suicide squad's great but i want to take
the time to um
to tell you guys about it the christmas
movie i came up with
last night um and it's it was inspired
by a dc movie called batman but i love
your suicide squad idea that does sound
great if it fits naturally
it fits very naturally it does actually
highlighting them makes it harder to
actually see i'll just put the arrow
here so people know we're talking about
them
but uh yeah if we did if they did a
suicide squad yeah okay
i love it i'm all for it it will work
perfectly they're already supposed to be
like a family in their own weird [ __ ]
up way
and then yeah he gets like violence up
and then by the end they're drinking
they're drinking at a bar and harley
quinn's got her
you know [ __ ] hat on the holiday hat
you know what i'm going with this all
right
yeah all right don don't half-ass this
one all right they could do it no
suicide squad plus suicide squad would
also lend itself to a holiday
anthology think of all the different
christmas-based and holiday-themed
operations we can see
multiple combinations doing
olivia that holiday special is happening
next year
so i would say uh okay i came
last night um took a little break out of
the evening to go watch elf with my
fiance oh
and i hadn't seen that movie since it
came out
on dvd when it first came out so i
barely remembered any of it
and uh i was watching it and i loved it
beautiful film but then i thought of my
own christmas movie that i would do
afterwards
and it was inspired by the batman
trailer
i was like what if it's a world where
everyone knows santa is real like
everyone knows sansa and they expect him
to come
every christmas what a cool world that
would be like they just know he's real
because every movie is about santa's not
real christmas spirit
and then oh my god santa's real i
believe in chris what if it's just the
world established
modern day and what people look forward
to once a year is santa coming around to
deliver presents
you know he's involved built his brand
involved with the community
right yeah yeah but then this but
there's a couple people who are not for
christmas you know and there's like a
detective who's like wife died on
christmas or something
yeah so he hates the day you know he
hates the day he doesn't he doesn't hate
he doesn't hate he's got trump but he's
not it's just not all about christmas he
drinks alone at the bar
you know and but then but then
santa is murdered oh that's where i
thought
of the batman trailer walking into the
crime scene
and he comes in and he has to follow the
clues as to who murdered santa who
decides who's naughty and he's going
into the underworld of the people who
are like anti-christmas
in a world where people know santa is
real
it's like who killed santa claus yeah it
would actually work it might be kind of
cool
that well yeah like a graphic novel
i've literally never thought about a
scenario where it's like what if
the real santa was murdered yeah what do
we do
that'd be crazy hey guys it's all
engagement if we've cracked four
dislikes now it's all engaged
also the algorithm yep hit as any
buttons of any kind as you like
share this anyway as long as we don't
hit the level of some people's
mandalorian reactions and reviews then
we're okay
as long as we don't hit that dead eyes
this counts maybe you guys know
who i'm referring to
[Music]
that was more than one like the explorer
where you can fill in the clues
way too long and now i've put us an hour
behind
it's okay it's okay deontay's back
no it's craig stratton again i'm just
saying i'm just saying i have a great
christmas movie idea all right craig
stratton
chicken run christmas special escape
christmas dinner dude
that's fantastic what an opportunity to
for a animal rights
themed christmas you know what you could
do for chicken and wrong people
christmas
can i interrupt
so the chickens are free oh no wow the
chickens are already free they aren't
free remember we've seen chicken run we
don't end mel gibson gets those hot
chicken babes out
so right no my idea is copyrighted right
now
and we'll tag you we'll claim you it's
right here this this is i'll claim
you're yeah it's all
copyrighted see that trailer if you
steal my ideas i'm just gonna copyright
claim it
um so
what was gonna say what was i talking
about chicken around chicken around
christmas special what they can be is
they're already free right they're
living their lives yeah but then they
see but then they say but then they see
but then they see
what they see what do they say they see
their turkeys who are in prison
oh dude so wait do they eat turkeys on
christmas you're more like yeah they're
turkey on christmas then you are chicken
right yeah yeah they bring out the
turkey not the not the cr not the
chicken
christmas turkey christmas trigger
christmas goose is like an older time
thing
because you're not just a different
animal and they gotta go help those
animals before they get turned to
christmas dinner
so instead of being like we're breaking
out of our own presents we gotta break
these
other people out yeah chicken run gobble
gobble
chicken dude perfect subtitle because of
the subtext about them all being eaten
you get it oh my god i thought this was
the scroll bar to go off of
i was like oh we're at the top
can you guys see this scroll bar all
right so there's a scroll bar here and i
was like oh we're at the top
and we have 23 notifications and then i
was like oh wait a minute
there's this other scroll bar here that
we have to get through
yeah yeah my bad in the update
uh where are we at uh craig stratton
chris
hi alexander cruz we're up to deontay
wimbish
deonte when bishop chung punch the fart
box ooh
deontay thank you deonte and thank you
craig for all you've contributed during
this room
it's been quite a few donations i
appreciate that um
do you want to take away deontay's i
would love to
ralph rex christmas to steer off a bit
who'd make a better christmas movie
tarantino or snyder
first off a ralph rex christmas i think
would be awesome
cause think about it i mean there are
plenty of like
holiday based games and game related
like sk you know every holiday like a
bunch of the app games on your phone or
changing skins for the holiday it's a
lot of fun you could have with that
as for a christmas movie
this is a real humdinger for me i think
i would be more
engrossed by an apt to enjoy whatever
tarantito comes up with for christmas
however
zack snyder's sensibility plus christmas
equals just question marks all around
for me
and in terra bangs like i've i've no
idea
what the vibe of zack snyder's christmas
movie would be and so part of me would
be tempted
to roll that dice because i feel like i
would love a tarantino christmas movie
because i think it would probably feel a
lot like once upon a time in los angeles
but with some kind of christmas
element or even if he did a period piece
but just like to see
what zack snyder is gonna do for
you know his take on a story that has
plenty of
darker tones in it uh i probably
would just for the what the [ __ ] factor
go there i feel like with the zack
snyder
christmas special what he would do is uh
he'd kill off
all the elves thinking it was a fun
easter egg
he's 20 20. your santa's not gonna be
some kind of like snowflake
compassionate
have jeffrey dean morgan play
have santa yes graphic sex scene with
him and mrs claus
yeah who's gonna be played by who's
who's uh uh carla gugino is mrs claus
and then uh it would be like a whole
last hour
of him delivering presents while santa
is like destroying buildings and
chimneys as he's trying to get
through and then there's a lot of
unnecessary slow motion every time he's
like
prancered take off somehow the altruism
of dealing with all these presents being
given out is going to become the most
harsh nihilist like people are going to
be trying to shoot santa out of the sky
and in the director's cut they're going
to be a bunch of flashbacks to
the christmas story filmed in slow
motion with like jesus
and mary and joseph and and then
yeah i think that would be it i think we
nailed down the zack snyder christmas
movie
i want that i wanna i want the
soundtrack to that hallelujah would play
at the end yep and some a little muse
somewhere
you patrick wilson will be in it he'll
be naked
um thank you deontay totally random talk
married would thank you totally random
talk marry with children christmas
special
oh that would be great getting married
with children back on the air for a
christmas special i would love that
reunion
oh we get to see how much more [ __ ]
that daughter has become christina
applegate oh
she's a total hooker at this absolute
vodka that was the whole thing about her
character as a prostitute
she worked at a brothel and then now
bunny he's super [ __ ] horny and a pig
he keeps going to serve clubs during
coven he goes to drive through strip
clubs
there's got to be one and then [ __ ]
the sun just keeps trying to get laid
nothing i think it would work i think it
would get views i think it's possible
and he also did totally random talk
modern christmas carol scripted short on
his channel last year
dude check that [ __ ] out a sec check out
that totally scripted christmas short
that would be great
miranda dandin mirna dannon just said in
this live stream too need a horror santa
ooh and she contributed 1.99 i
appreciate that mirna
rare exports don't they have a horror
yeah they have a horror santa
got a couple they actually you know what
i never knew is that there's a
movie within a movie in earnest saves
christmas called santa's
sleigh i believe which i i don't think
it's like the same movie but there
literally is an 80s
slasher flick called santa's slayer
early 90s about a killer santa
um silent night deadly night um
uh yeah there are at least a few evil
scenes german trailer one i saw
i think it was a german movie it was it
wasn't krampus
and it wasn't rare exports it might have
is that like a creepy kind of skinny
yeah and he's like it's in some
mountains cold
isolated yeah yeah that's then then yeah
that's the one yeah i'm sorry
and they're actually if you look around
the fat thor becomes a mall santa while
rocket is head
elf would be a great christmas special
yes
and daryl's the manager oh that would be
awesome that would be great
i love that one oh avengers headquarters
santaland
sweet nan nan happy holidays y'all
thank you sweet and then happy holidays
to you too as well
oh how's your nan doing so how do you
nan nam for me
so how do you nan nam for me there are a
lot of great king of the hill christmas
episodes
bt dubs um who's a strip club that works
like a car wash
how does that work maggie aaron oh but
if they're stripping and they're like
like a sexy bikini car
or when we lived together
yeah and then the gas station literally
right next door to us
yeah like if you step outside it's right
next to you
yeah they had a bikini car wash going on
once
yeah and because oh because i'm right
i'm in a relationship i was like don't
look
drive go cut it gun it through the
alleyway
into the turn onto the other street that
will not be open for you at the
intersection
oh i you know that gas station came in
real handy what my gap my car ran out of
gas
in in in the garage there and it
normally
my first thought was oh oh [ __ ] and then
i was like oh i could
walk over there and get some gas bring
it back
maggie aaron thank you so much maggie
just have to say you both are awesome
you're awesome maggie thank you you're
awesome
i hope you're having a good holiday i
hope you know i'll always love you and
hey
chime in guys with all your great picks
and ideas but also what you guys are
doing to celebrate and feel festive in
this weird year
did they just release the spider-man 3
trailer i'm just joking
you had me going for a second we got to
stop the stream
christmas christmas
um living freak
how about 300 snyder christmas cut
might as well i have seen on i think it
was maybe nat geo or the history channel
like
like a bible i don't know if it was the
christmas story or the passion but it
was shot
with the exact like clearly someone saw
300 and wanted to make the bible this
way
and like it was it was one of those
moments where like i would joke about
this but this just is a joke i've made
so so if you want it it's out there
pop culture podcasters [ __ ] you for that
all right we'll refund your super chats
um
you know what i'm sorry man you can take
down our episodes
i i didn't mean it we should just do a
separate video of like
spider-man here we go here we go
and then do an upload like five minutes
later going without sorry guys
didn't mean to get y'all's hopes up
let's see here uh living freak
back at it talking about how about how
about
a christmas special that can't be shown
ever because the movie theater equipment
breaks down
every time you play it
the other one [ __ ] up the my
spider-man 3 comment that i've just made
you would ruin so much property you
would destroy
theaters that are already ailing oh it
would
it would take on such an internet like
urban legend being live
it would be that's you live up to your
name man you lose your name moving freak
you're my kind of guy
it'd be the polybius of uh big screen
christmas specials
they should just do a mel gibson holiday
special yeah
yeah you know where he reflects on the
spirit of the season
you know with his santa beard kicks into
the door to a synagogue as i want to
tell you jews about christmas
yeah he breaks in during some hanukkah
festivities
celebrating the wrong day let me tell
you about my friend jesus
this this movie i made on for you oh
living freak you
you are a crazy man all right guys look
we're gonna we got to go through the the
last of these super chats and such i
appreciate
everyone who's been here this entire
time and contributed
but we're going to ask you kindly
to withdraw from contributing more super
chats this is this is
super generous of you guys really really
i'm grateful
but we do got to get some more work
um in terms of editing and filming and
maybe this too this tune sandwich [ __ ]
came out huh
maybe maybe if we have time
we could put up the reaction in yeah the
morning i might want to wash this
this seems like a pretty fun thing it
seems like it would be probably a good
idea for us
you know considering the fact that our
two sandwich ones did well anyway
happy christmas eve rosie happy
christmas eve uh
josiahgamer123 thank you josiah american
pie
christmas special i'm surprised it's not
happened at least on the straight to
video markets
yeah but why hasn't it happened
i don't know maybe you know don't eat
that pie
don't eat that fruit cake and it's just
jason biggs having sex with the
fruitcake instead because they got like
a big old homemade they did a reunion
one and maybe they could do another one
where they come back
together for a christmas reunion yeah
american high christmas reunion
yeah that's just a genuinely good idea
yup
call up james stiffler's not doing
anything he's got he's got time
and jason biggs there they all got time
clark jack and jill a very merry holiday
special
oh yeah that's what everyone wants for
adam sandler to return back to the
back to the [ __ ] uh yeah bring al
pacino along for the ride
oh my goodness now pacino dresses santa
and then do a grown-ups holiday special
what you can do is uh uh yeah if you get
out but
if you get robert de niro in al pacino
back for a jack and jill holiday special
oh
looky there oh that would be so good
yeah and martin scorsese back
boom and joe pesci and harvey carson
and ray leota and
joe vidarelli was
who's the one in uh robert duvall
yeah roberts there you go andy garcia
garcia yeah who's who plays fredo
he's dead yeah he's dead he can't get
him back dude we can
see his face on to a body double though
don't think that we
it's a documentary no one's gonna cause
a ruckus wow
cancel john yep bring it back hashtag
hashtag hush talk passion
john is consoled they're hashing talks
in germany
pop culture podcasts um
thank you buddy borat subsequent
christmas film
oh yeah for make mary the glorious
nation of kazakhstan and the fact that
that borat movie just became
it just became a [ __ ] family movie
halfway they like
really turned into one dude tutor and
borah need to have a holiday sasha baron
cohen get your ass on it quit
slacking off sasha baron cohen yeah well
you're the
laziest guy in hollywood what are you
doing out here
making secret movies and releasing them
by surprise get off your ass and make
your
borax christmas movie yeah and then
bruno
and then we'll talk sweet nan back at it
thank you and then i watched the heck
out of sandy bullock and george clooney
leading an ocean's holiday themed heist
i would be
well forth they gotta they gotta rob
rockefeller center or something
oh yeah they gotta steal a christmas
steal the giant got a tree they gotta
steal a giant christmas tree
yeah they will yeah they'll come over
the whole plan about how to make it
disappear and swap it out with a fake
tree but it would really be a hologram
tree that they're recording from like a
secret location
with a replica they built to the tree
that's gonna be good i just gotta say
you know this stream has been full of
terrible ideas and
some amazing terribly good ideas this is
a great idea i really i have
faith i have faith in these ideas and
hey yeah i know i mean
i appreciate everyone who keeps
contributing right now
yes i almost read one prematurely other
people
that's okay for now it's all right guys
we're catching up
cancel culture doesn't suck mirna it's
revolutionized the world
accountability culture is my favorite
culture
i'm glad we're here where are we at
we are at a initiative okay carlos
so remember when i freaked out about
carlos being in the chat yeah 43 minutes
ago
we finally got up to him man
i met greg and i already told the story
and laura stopped again
lauren got marie in a in person a long
time ago and i'm really glad to see
you're all doing so well so many years
later
well i don't really talk to lauren gaw
i'm marie sometimes
john has morphed into marine and yeah
carlos i remember your name i'll never
forget it
i've made it i've made i will never
forget carl i had i
he didn't even ask for a picture oh i
asked for a picture
i said it can i get a picture see a
picture with you man
you [ __ ] did it i am proud do you
still have it
is it is it it's on the ground it's
gotta be on the ground somewhere there
you gotta search back for it i love you
man thank you for showing up here i love
you carlos
i'll never forget you remember the
ability to be recognized in public
it still happens i gotta recognize a
tenant with a mask on
really that's and i went hey man nice to
meet you
shake my
there's nobody at this theater we're
both fine not a big deal
[Music]
that's cool you are thank you i miss you
buddy you're amazing gg
a purge christmas special dude they move
it
santa getting rid of that's when you do
everyone always has that idea santa
going after the naughty kid
battle royale that's when you do santa
getting rid of the naughty
kids the naughty is it this time of year
the that's when he goes out there
there's literally people left and right
the naughty kids are literally just
put into a pen to do with each other
what they please
that that is i'm just saying santa takes
advantage oh santa just kills them all
yeah
yeah oh even better there's no plot
it's just a string of murders you know
the purge movies they always set
themselves up for oh this is going to be
psychologically challenging
this is going to have a lot of
commentary about it yes system and
society no commentary that'll just be
kind of dark and cool but in a dark way
you know it'd be funny oh yeah actually
there is a way to do a purge
this is why we take so long because we
spent too long sometimes on these john
but
i have to i have to go for it there's a
way to do a purge christmas special okay
the family gets together and you know
that's set up with those movies of like
i hate being around my family let's just
get around just let's just have fun
let's just pretend put on a smile
i know my mom could be judgmental i i
know my dad he's a [ __ ] i'm
doing the everybody loves raymond cast
is what i'm doing
you know blah blah blah and then they go
we have an exciting announcement
we have moved the purge to today
for christmas and then battle royale
breaks out with the family it could be
like the ready or not movie speaking of
which i feel like those ready or not
guys could do a great purge movie
oh yeah that would be a good idea call
hollywood have you have you seen ready
or not yet
nope but i know radio silence why would
you say that would be a great idea
because i've seen a couple
other of their works and they were stand
out
in those works although i i
yeah and i'm all for it john thank you i
appreciate that
oh man i wish i knew how to read this
gave me the language
um this is japanese is this japanese
this if i think it's japanese anybody
know
how to say this person's name i'm pretty
sure it's japanese but that's all i got
japanese man thank you or otherwise
masanya i hope to meet you do too okay i
hope this goes through but i'm so happy
i found you live i love your channel
so much because you guys made me smile
through tough times i'm really happy to
donate to your names all
happy holidays thank you so much i wish
i knew how to say your name
i wish i knew how to say your name but
happy holidays to you too
i hope you're having a great time and
i'm so happy that we get to make you
smile occasionally
you know sometimes our videos are like
yeah we do daily videos so not all the
time are we going to be sharp and on top
of it
but every once in a while i think we do
do videos that are like hey that's good
like like recently this this thing
happened where tom cruise yelled at
people on set
and i don't know if you guys have heard
me talk about this yet but
that we did this bit where we like
chanted tom cruise's name in the mission
impossible tune
i got a copyright so i can ruin the fun
of ever watching that video again
but but it's videos like that where i'm
like oh people might laugh when we do
this so we should do it
hello darkness uh
i've come to talk with ben affleck
so guys john has had this paused
on our screen as you can see it's very
early on in the stream well every once
in a while
it's supporting the pop-out chat every
once in a while to check
john's reaction to a joke i make i'll
i'll look
in this in this screen here
i'll show you guys it just looks the
word
it looks like that is that it am i doing
it right now yes
somewhere there it looks like that so
then i'll look there
but when i looked to see john's reaction
i saw this and i was like
what the [ __ ] is jon staring at me
i'm staring waiting for humor
this is what i do guys i give you guys
the raw behind the scenes roman
ronin samayou is that how you say the
price ronan somayou thank you ronan
yes ronan and are you is it chinese or
japanese we're [ __ ] stupid
you know the purge one made me think
just as a quick sidebar
you know that that on purge day certain
people are probably out robbing stores
being like
if i make it home i am so ahead on my
christmas tree
like it's got to be happening for
somebody it just has to
that's funny
sidebar complete let's move on
uh sean davis what's up buddy thank you
sean merry christmas greg and john
s d i would love to see a doom patrol
holiday special that would be
perfect judging by they should do
that and hbo max is competing with
disney plus
they should get themselves a holiday
special and do it with doom patrol
it would be the most [ __ ] up weird
christmas special you have ever seen and
i would love it
broaden that genre out broaden the
christmas genre out
with more and more kookiness oh that
would be lovely because it would be
like i you know i haven't seen the show
yet but i imagine it would lead to
something very original
for christmas dude you didn't say the
thing where you said
uh from what i've seen of the show or
the bits and pieces i've seen you just
admitted
i haven't seen the show yet it's a year
full of new and interesting leaves for
john what
who are you i'm just taking notes every
time
oh my god john
john that was that was blunt all right
that was for that's your christmas
present
everything else i brought today is for
olivia wreckadea look i know we're like
an hour and a half into the stream you
got to go way back to the beginning of
our stream we appreciate the super chat
buddy
boys but we pitched the ultimate boys
holiday special no super early on in
this stream
so and i'm telling you racket deal
you're going to love it
go back i appreciate your wrap yourself
i appreciate it
how are you doing how uh how are you
doing uh i need to
slowly been catching up on messages on
patreon but i hope you're doing well
buddy seriously i hope you're doing well
this is the point of the stream where
greg starts getting more sincere
ah chill level tv well chill level let's
talk about it
hashtag john watch doom patrol seriously
john what are you doing with your life
uh anything are you doing anything for
your life
i don't do anything most days i wake up
i sit someone tells me to move and then
i move
and then i sit some more and then i stop
chill level tv hello rejects
hello to you i'm gonna let john read
this one
hello rejects here are my picks for
films and series that deserve holiday
specials
an evil dead christmas a john wick
christmas
i got a treat for you a fast and f i got
an even bigger treat for you
faster furious christmas a cowboy bebop
christmas a
tron christmas and a mandalorian
christmas thoughts
i mean where do you want us to start hi
maria merry christmas
marie maria um see ya
an evil dead christmas you know what
you're talking about we covered john
wick christmas we cover fast and furious
christmas a cowboy beep pop christmas
would be cool
jazz we have talked about mandalorian
okay an evil dead christmas john take it
away you got
30 seconds all right ashes at smart
selling
ugly christmas sweaters oh good then
over here oh what happens some old lady
comes in and starts giving him a hassle
and he's
trying to remain patient because it's
the holidays and she's got a little kid
with her
but then he realizes the kid's a dead
eye and then he has to
shoot the kid and the grandma but then
everyone in the store is like what are
you doing man this is insane
and then uh you know then everyone
thinks ash is like a murderer on
christmas but then
it turns out that there's an even bigger
threat uh of krampus is in the
the the necronomicon and he's been
unleashed somehow and and that's who ash
has to fight for christmas
all right you went over your timeline
unfortunately we have to move on to
someone else's idea
you did it nah give me another shot let
me just go one more time hey a
spider-verse christmas special would be
cool when dex i love that idea there's
already snow in the movie
it lends itself perfectly anything with
snow
can be christmas i actually think a
saniverse movie would be cool too
into the santa vs the santa vs santa man
into this antiverse
and let's get a jesus verse too there
have been a lot of on-screen jesus sees
jesus gonna do an unpacking video for
christmas we
we did we get maria's package yet
i haven't received a notification we
have a p.o box now guys
but we haven't gotten a notification yet
for it i yeah
this one are you the one from providence
rhode island
maria is this humorous
bye mirna bye oh have a good good day
night evening
morning any any which way if you're not
the one from providence rhode is we got
to open some of these
oh yeah we should open some of these
let's open them live we're supposed to
be getting more packages too
all right anyway we'll film unboxings
anyway
chill level on christmas day pop culture
podcasts here we go
pcp baby driver christmas special
wait maria you didn't answer my question
is this one you
because there's no name on here no
return
it's not and we have to do no it's not
you no
no damn not maria okay well we haven't
got a notification for the p.o box yeah
and i'll check as soon as we hop off
no i mean we have we have the po box
thing we haven't got a notification
not yet so it may be uh [ __ ]
corporate offices
sorry maria but we will unbox it on
camera
when it comes to us you have our word
we're gonna unbox it on camera
yes you have our word what's our what's
our box number
uh we'll tell you we'll put it down
later
we'll put a link in the description um
no what does she mean no no that's not
i think we're having a delay in the
interaction with maria
yeah maybe is it no that's not the card
i think it's just because
we've we're like uh going back and forth
yeah yeah so much that i think i think
it's because we're waiting for
instantaneous response but there's a lag
with the live stream
that's a very good maria when we have
the box we'll know it's from you and we
will unbox it on camera
for sure put it up on patreon absolutely
thank you thank you for sending
something our way yes we i already
watched the finale of rebels
son greg some colorado gas
[Laughter]
okay pop culture podcast baby driver
christmas special where santa is running
late and needs help delivering his
presence as fast
as possible and and
and you could do it to a bunch of
christmas tunes absolutely you could
edit it to christmas
and he's got a whole playlist that you
could would make a perfect soundtrack
tie-in
awesome i do too i love it i do too and
then
somewhere along the way he meets up with
the fast family
and then they all deliver presents
together
don't worry maria we got you covered we
got you covered just not with this
envelope i like that pop culture podcast
but we'll keep an eye out
all right guys we're almost done here
with you then we'll take some from just
the chat
but we're almost there all righty roger
bob334
bobby roger rabbit christmas special
that's well maybe easter's special with
roger as the easter bunny
i i wish i thought it's got to be a
christmas i would love it
a roger rabbit christmas special they
have been we wanted a [ __ ] sequel for
so long we haven't got any yet
might as well do a roger rabbit
christmas sequel yeah
did i say a proper sentence there yeah
you might as well do a roger rabbit
christmas special
yeah absolutely i mean think of all the
classic christmas cartoons
you could bring into toontown i'm
craving pizza
i am craving pizza
this pizza does sound really good right
now it does like sometimes you say a
food and just the image pops up into
your mind you're just like yeah yeah
yeah i'm most excited for hayden
christensen coming back
but thank you bob 334 that's a great
idea
flev doran flevy d yeah um okay we were
giving him we were just ripping you
about having to come with an actual plot
for the boys and he's saying oh do i
actually have to write a script
i just i thought just naming a popular
ip like the boys and throwing some ideas
and leave the underpaid screenwriters
filling the gas is how you sell a show
in hollywood
okay opening a word document now and
then he's
he hopped to here i'm actually taking
this way too
seriously and my mind is getting a
little had to take over the plot
anyway gonna check out merry christmas
guys happy holidays everyone chat bye
ways christmas steve now here in romania
happy merry christmas merry christmas
it's okay man that's all you have to do
is suggest a little idea
that's all you see we used to have uh we
used to have
um uh
uh we were trying out a segment for a
little bit called uh
how it could work we're basically we
take
ideas of like we did like how you could
reboot fry the 13th
before split was released we wrote one
for um
unbreakable too and people really liked
these
ideas like they we really wrote them out
and we like
outlined the [ __ ] out of them we
actually had little writers we would
think about like okay but how would the
character arc
go but no this beat doesn't make sense
to have like we really
mapped it out we just do yeah like it
would take like a week
to assemble yeah and i thought it would
be such an easy thing but i'm like this
this takes too much yeah because it's
the kind of thing where you're like yeah
if we just you know get the idea out you
know and then you you end up with too
much footage and then you're like i
gotta
cut this down and then i gotta make this
thing flow and then yeah
we don't know any animators who could do
this yeah we can't afford an animator
is this interesting enough on its own as
just a podcast
uh joe o'keefe thank you jokey
how about a shire based christmas
special hey that'd be lovely
yeah mary mother brandy book
and are the rosencratz in
guildenstern voice of the purple guiding
us through it all
gandalf will bookend the story ps i'm
about a third of the way through a
bottle of whiskey
there you go joe keefe happy
well dude i love your idea for lord of
the rings christmas special especially
with the hobbits i feel like
they deserve one they deserve one it
should be on hbo max it's for the lord
of the rings movies are do a christmas
special on hbo maxwell yeah or
or tie it into the new lead off the new
amazon
show with a christmas special doctor who
style i mean i want the
the hol the lord and lord of the rings
show to be like an anthology series
within the lord of the rings universe i
don't think they're going to do that but
if they were to do their christmas
special
hobbits love a good party they love good
food i mean their christmas would be
pretty rad especially if gandalf rolls
through
pop culture podcast
pop culture podcast one of my favorite
movies of all time
should have a christmas special a big
lebowski christmas
this aggression towards the holidays
will not stand
man do your jeff bridge's impression in
saying that line
river questions for the holidays will
not stare
man i just actually
saw i'll say two-thirds
of the big lebowski sequel the other day
is it awful it was not great it was it
was not it did not look good
it was not terrific
yeah and it's also a remake of a
different european movie that's already
well established so it's like a spin-off
remake of something else spin-off remake
sequel
yeah exactly uh but yeah big lebowski
christmas special it would
it would come with a perfect tie-in
drink
if you made some kind of sugar cookie
white russian or something like that
maybe some nihilist eggnog you know i've
been seeing a lot in the chat about
kevin sheppard just brought up a
breaking bad christmas special would be
cool
jesse we have to cook eggnog we have to
cook for the family we have to cook for
this beast
all my hidden relatives are coming into
town
chili pee no the get them spicy jesse
i am the one who cooks i have the one
who bakes
i want that as well man that was good i
appreciate it
nmb thank you buddy mission impossible
theme song christmas special
i'm trying to think how it could
[Music]
like how can you make this like a major
a major key song or something like that
just imagine like sleigh bells jingling
in the back this video is going to get
claimed because
[Music]
country boys love you too buddy
azim the dream reviews i love that what
a great love your name
out of all the news we've gotten on
legacy characters for oh i answered your
question in the chat
what are you most excited about for me
it's the original trio jurassic world
dominion samuel jeff goldblum and laura
durham with chris pratt and bice
uh i would i mean that sounds cool and
all but the franchise
lately i'm just not a big fan of what i
would say
is my favorite the one i'm most the one
i'm really
most looking forward to is uh in
all sincerity hayden christensen
as anakin skywalker be both
hayden christensen and um evan mcgregor
because evan mcgregor we know is a great
actor
and he's arguably the best thing about
those prequels
hayden christensen there's been a lot of
i think the love for the anakin
skywalker character has gotten a lot
more
love especially because of how great he
is
in clone wars and
our attachment towards anakin has made
us kind of appreciate because of
that the the image and likeness and all
that
stemmed from hayden christensen's
portrayal
so i think more of our attachments our
danican can stem
from that but let's all remember we all
thought he sucked
when he came out right yeah and i'm like
but maybe but hey christian's done good
work in other films
so putting him under the strengths of a
different director and a different tone
and world establishment in star wars
getting a chance to properly represent
himself
as an actor for the star wars and
getting a chance to show like no i could
have done this well
that's what gets me more excited there's
something he can prove with that and i
think that's why um
i wish i had said that in the video
[Music]
uh when we talked about it so i want to
take a chance to
to get very serious here tell you guys
about
why i think hayden christensen
might do an all right job
[Laughter]
i've seen him act in other things and
he's all right sometimes
seen a shattered glass and it was pretty
good toby maguire for me though
oh yeah toby maguire [ __ ] no [ __ ] all
the editing [ __ ] what the hell am i
talking about
the tobii is one of my favorite comic
book movies
i like it that's my favorite spider-man
movie hands down
so yeah what am i talking about don't be
required
and and that i mean to me was something
where like you know those i remember so
vividly those movies bought i mean like
seeing the first spider-man in the
theaters of my dad seeing uh
spider-man 2 i you know even i remember
seeing spider-man 3
and i never thought that something like
this could or would happen and
it's it's not yet fully confirmed
[ __ ] that up but uh yeah you're right
about that i'm so excited for that like
genuinely and truthfully
all right guys last few super chats of
the day pop culture podcast
last super chat for me cut off just to
say happy holidays and i appreciate guys
hopefully all three of us in an episode
of my podcast sometime next year for
sure man that'd be awesome
but yeah go go listen there's a greg
episode and a john episode on the pcp
taking
any extended break for the holidays we
we we're trying to
prep videos for that's why we have to
end the stream trying to prep videos
at least one to go by christmas eve and
on christmas day if there's a spider-man
3 trailer
that's the only thing that can get me
away for an hour and a half to two hours
yes to step away like god damn it
it's spider-man 3 trailer the trailer
but anything else there's nothing on
that could get me to stop
step away from from spending quality
time with loved ones and taking a bit of
a break
um but yeah so that's the only exception
we'll make to actually
film something is spider-man 3. but
thank you for asking and yes
he has a wonderful podcast and he's a
great interview or a pop culture podcast
go listen that means
a wonderful podcast available where
podcasts are available
riot ryan with a 40 one wow what a
big one thank you dude that's huge thank
you much love thank you so much
you've made my christmas we can afford
to buy presents now
john and i can split this and give
presents to each other we can each give
each other some mcdonald's
hey guys love you both well we love you
now
especially especially
thank you seriously thank you all the
silliness
seriously would you like to see a would
you like to see
direct a horror style christmas movie
yes i would i've i've talked about this
yeah who would you like to see direct a
horror style christmas movie
oh who yes
what about this a horror movie set at
christmas
what i i do think oh hillary b i i do
think that um
don't want to say jordan peel because
everyone [ __ ] says jordan
uh yeah you can't say jordan peele you
can't say taika white teeny
yes
even though tycho would make a great
christmas movie
well i think it would need to be like a
horror comedy
yes who
could do that shane black ryan
johnson ryan i really think he could do
a good one
he managed to do a murder mystery that
took place
during the was it during the holidays
okay here's my defense for why ryan
johnson
director of films like looper brick and
knives out
and everyone's favorite star wars i
wasn't going to mention that one
no what are you buying what do you mean
but ryan johnson
yes did knives out came out around
thanksgiving last year if i'm not
mistaken
and going to the theaters during the
holidays
it's not a holiday film but somehow
there was something about we're like
this weirdly fits for the holidays i can
see why this is a box office hit during
the holidays it weirdly fits
hey merry christmas rosie we appreciate
all the facts we've
shot the doctor who reaction today
appreciate all the facts sent over a lot
and we commented on pretty much every
one of them
excited thank you share it with you and
maria
you managed to kill a franchise too he's
gonna kill christmas
he's gonna kill all christmas movies
because of this one
i'm saying that he managed to pull off
one that felt appropriate that was a
murder wrist around christmas ever
that felt like yeah i could watch this
during the holidays and so i feel like
he could pull off a christmas movie yeah
subvert expectations it's really a
hanukkah
what i thought i was celebrating all
along is actually hanukkah
i want a charlie kaufman directed
christmas film that would be great
yeah that would be very psychological
and
and hard to to wrap your heart around
but yeah or spike jones i mean he's
already done stuff that has holidays in
it but i feel like a spike jones
christmas movie proper
uh i'd say charlie crawford charlie
living freak arachnophobia
holiday special
dude yeah little spider hats little
santa hats all the spiders
thing you know that's even that's
funnier when
john's face is this close to you
that might not have been so funny
grinning that might have been
funny you're watching it from your
perspective
but he just looks at you like a little
spider hats
like that spider-man little sweater at
script
that wouldn't be bad thank you
arachnophobia holiday i mean thank you
thank you erectophobia you really made
my ear
that's already in the doctor who
christmas special oh the last one was i
i should have gone for a different
horror director i flubbed that one
i did i did i'm not i'm not gonna take
it back
dolan duck i think i know who this is
dull and just
it's not joystick i wanna be jason dylan
it's an sck
yeah yeah uh i don't really have triceps
today schmodown entertainment
network oh you got you got seps of
all over you got tried the lighting's
ruining yeah let me get really far away
and reduce some of these lights
turn these lights really make it look
like it's popular light you you ever go
to a mirror and then you stand really
far away and like damn i see muscles
this is my situation oh thank you maria
you're so sweet thank you that's such a
sweet comment
ari astor should not direct a christmas
horde
esther oh he shouldn't i a fight club
christmas i love that
fight club christmas is good and our
last super chat of the day
but yeah thank you dolan duck appreciate
that man
craig i don't know what that means but
okay um
merry christmas love you guys hillary b
we love you
too you [ __ ] love thank you for being
here and for showing your
thank you love and kindness all these
crazy chats
you guys rock merry christmas to you all
all right let's end this in a couple
minutes let's end this with us we gotta
film some [ __ ] and edit some [ __ ]
and take a [ __ ] oh yeah and uh
spit on some kids no i wish i could riff
on the x-files
one but what i can say leonardo is
a hannibal christmas special he loves to
cook
he does think i think you should do it
think of him baking like christmas
cookies but with a cannibal twist
i like turtle a ninja turtles holiday
special
i'm surprised that's not already the
creepy ones that we have right
yes the creepy live-action one good
night chelsea brown
merry christmas and uh and uh i almost
called her
what's her name megan fox there you go i
almost called her michaela
her character name from transformers
she has a name in his movies i think
it's michaela
i'm not sure
yeah megan fox and shia labeouf the lead
characters in the transformers
uh um marissa thank you marissa
sweet welcome so sweet marissa i hope
you enjoy all that we have to offer you
so sweet maurice david lynch christmas
yes i want a panos cosmatos horror
christmas movie
laura meets the incredibles
only that one mcu character though only
that one
meets the incredibles this is a random
one
plucked out into the incredibles see him
why the [ __ ]
thanks disney why not
adios maria a home alone christmas movie
really make it
just no now we start needing to take uh
uh christmas
movies and crossing them over so how
about chris
uh uh home alone but also gremlins
or kevin mcallister accidentally waters
some gremlins while he's home alone
and he's got bandits breaking i love the
way you think i
love the way you talk durian the room
absolutely chill level tv i'm with you a
hundred percent
mark lee do you guys see his comment
inception prequel where they
they were younger they go into their
parents stream she suggests christmas
presents to them
that is abusing the system
that's not what this technology is for
oh my god
and you could do it in like an animation
style that harkens back to like charlie
brown
because then that would sell it atomic
cyborg
take care wait what's not trending
talking about
i'm ready to get into a fight right now
i'll do it i'll throw it down
i'll punch this camera i'll break this
camera right now it's not ours
or second or third break that last like
camera break that lens if someone's
trying to start some [ __ ] jason dolan be
on standby in case we break trying to
start some [ __ ]
yeah yo we were at 180 earlier
oh cool yeah that's awesome i think we
broke 200 at one point oh cool
that's a christmas miracle in and of
itself for like uh it's pretty crazy for
200 viewers i mean [ __ ] i loved it i
love the numbers here
it's an intimate show it's an intimate
show
oh not trying to i think i think not
trend is trying to start a fight
oh i think we should do it i think it's
a good idea to start a fight not trend
if you show if you change your profile
pic on youtube on your youtube user and
you throw your
you throw your face on there then
i will assume you were man enough to
engage in an argument with me
all right but if you're going to keep
hiding then i'm going to look at
all to be [ __ ] the icons until we see
your face
yeah get ready you're not ready so get
ready
or or you know what uh nah he's boring
ah there we go bye anyway guys get some
last minute questions that i'm gonna end
this
last-minute amas about the holidays
science okay no we already did a
hannibal christmas special scott pilgrim
christmas special that could work
yeah that could definitely work i mean
think of
all the the like with all those
ex-boyfriends there's got to be a lot of
holiday feels to work through
were we trying to act big we i guess
were we
yeah i guess we were trying to actually
trying to act big yeah is that what
happened
well i'm always trying to act big i'm
always trying to be
my britches i always want to feel like
they're not enough to support how big i
am
austin powers
would make a good christmas special we
got more to film and i'm just like
i'm tired already a little bit but it's
okay we'll power through
yeah babe
there's a lot of amazon packages i did
all my christmas shopping at the very
last minute guys
don't open any of them
i will look at them in one minute guys i
gotta go look at some amazon packages
oh that's how we should end the streams
oh opening gifts
yeah you're not even gonna are you gonna
watch the stream too watch me open it
oh this is so beautiful i almost i'm
gonna take a picture
oh wait no i don't think any of those
presents are for you find john's gift
i'm taking but find john's gift
that's how i'm going to pick because
this is so nicely wrapped
all right here we go i'm tearing in the
top ooh
there's what's inside we established at
the very plan not to contribute anything
kevin
yes kevin you're exempt
i'm trying to preserve this and not
doing a good job all right
i just watched this asmr style all right
let me just hold your mic for you yes
all right
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna open it
towards you guys
i don't even know i don't even know what
could it be
what could it be
oh sick demon
slayer thank you of course ah this is
awesome i've
i'm gonna i hope the movie comes at some
point because i'm gonna be rocking the
[ __ ] out of this unlike my faux pas
for our my hero
this is awesome and yeah the whole uh
season if anybody doesn't know we've
done
reactions over on the pate me myself and
i thank you
i'm gonna put this on right now but if
you want to come and pledge i'd suggest
doing it next year so that way you don't
get charged
on january
next yeah next saturday that's why we
don't plug on
this later to the month usually but for
those of you who
have a calendar and can remind
yourselves to wait
did you give me a gift i did you want it
i know me i mean i got you guys
narcissistic
christmas this will be great because i
put these together
in a way where mmb you've made my year
okay [ __ ] with you man what i'm gonna do
is i'm going to pull out
because most of what's in here is for
you
most most of what's in here is for you
and there's one
thing don't get don't bring john's gift
i need to get more gifts okay
i'm just gonna i oh [ __ ] it's okay i'll
hold your mic
now okay
what the [ __ ] man okay that morning
that is uh going back in the box going
back in the bag
i'm doing this the old school oh it's
all good it's all good
wrap these early this morning guys have
a good day good night good evening
whatever
wherever whenever you are
those of you lucky enough to still have
your lives
take them with you is that kill bill yes
this is the bride
oh [ __ ]
yes yes but he'll get more gifts
[Music]
thank you so john got me this shirt oh
what a cool shirt
these are yeah this is a special line
that huff did uh and i i grabbed one
before they all got sold out
john don't open your gift you'll need to
get i need to get you more
gift no dude no you do enough for me
it's just by
existing and and don't say that propping
me up through this life
what's this huh
little little mystery little little toy
guy
yeah eat that packaging all right
do you know what's in here no they're a
mystery it's the whole point
that's the fun of it all i gave you a
marvel one
that turned into thor like last last
year i think
who'd you get oh a drax one it looks
like kratos
it looks like kratos it's dual purpose
it's for both fandoms
oh thank you buddy it's a mysterious
which is actually probably better we
open this here so the cats are getting
those thank you you're welcome you're
welcome happy
happy holiday happy christmas and then
uh
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah okay and i mean the
bucket too is yours
i keep the bucket all right john open
the one gift i got you
all right i'm gonna grab the uh and then
we're ending this stream because there's
no other better way to end the street
no better there's no better place than
here and no better time than now
i just get you shirts all the time so i
was like i need to get you something
that's not a t-shirt
i like that i mean i i deliberated but
then i was like ah damn but
but this this this seems like something
kind of special so
as much as i am also in the mode of like
yeah we should probably
i can't give you only t-shirts but when
a good one comes along
all right i'm i'm gonna open it out ways
you don't have to do that
but that's the fun part oh
damn ah this is awesome
it's the big four right yeah am i
missing count am i missing anybody it's
a big
four freddy it's it's michael myers
harry warden one of the gremlins
and dracula all the best
horror movie no yeah freddie jason
leatherface and michael thank you
the other one wouldn't have gotten here
on time it's okay it was an inch bigger
you know what i was like maybe i'll just
this is perfect
i should have i'm gonna hang it in my
corner i'll hang it in my corner
where i uh shoot videos oh
nice thank you you're welcome oh i feel
so nice
guys these are my first christmas
presents of 2020. merry christmas to you
all
and a happy new year oh yeah that's
right wait a minute you get the one-two
punch of it being olivia and i
yeah olivia president i absolutely did
and i got your cat i got a present
thank you guys so much for being here
you guys have helped christmas be so
special
i love all the suggestions i love the
batman i really idea
bradley blitz so you rock dark side
master
guys start saying bye and we'll start
saying bye to you
personally let's get this goodbyes on
bradley jay merry christmas cash riddell
merry christmas happy holidays timmy
turtle merry christmas
dark side master you filthy animal
kevin shepard merry christmas
thanks for being part of our patreon
page by the way kevin windex
james windall tm
thank you very much
thanks for to everybody who showed up
earlier sean
chill level tv moses max
pcp pop culture bradley blood soap pop
culture dark yoda i thought you left out
rosie turtle our x mills
fun stuff yes merry christmas
merry christmas to you today oh moses
reed happy birthday again
good night happy to all into all
a good happy see you guys take care
woo 21 bricks 21